okay so the draw Muhammad cartoon has
been controversial and it's been talked
about everywhere let's just get to it I
wonder whether this group that held this
event down there to basically disparage
and to make fun of the Prophet Muhammad
doesn't in some way cause these events
without the word causing how about
provoking how about wanting how about
daring what how do you see thee of the
causality factor here okay this was not
designed to provoke to make fun of to be
vulgar it was drawing a picture drawing
a picture is not hatred
unless hateful people are now making the
rulebook you understand this look I
don't want to be insulting the freedom
of speech everyone has the right to
freedom of speech and it's good to stand
by that principle and then he's gonna
tell you exactly why he doesn't stand by
that principle these people are not
standing by that principle they're
spending by the principle of hatred for
other people that's their guiding light
that's what they do they are
intentionally trying to provoke a
response from the Muslim community and
unfortunately this was predictable and
you know that because the police told
them in order to hold this event they
would have to have $10,000 worth of
security on hand they had a SWAT team
outfitted like it was Baghdad so
obviously someone knew that there was a
likelihood that some stupid person would
do this
somebody's gonna skim over the fact that
if you're going to have an event where
you draw a picture the only time where
security comparable to Baghdad is
necessary is when you're drawing
Mohammed that's the only time and then
we go right into because some stupid
person might make some stupid person no
an ideologue someone who follows Islam
you can't skim over it and then just say
some stupid person and again I don't
think it's any great revelation that if
you shout fire in a crowded theater and
you incite people and you say nasty
invective about people's ancestors and
their religious symbols that there are a
couple of crazy nut cases that are going
to come out of the woodwork and are
going to try to take action over that
but that has nothing to do with this
long yelling fire in a crowded theater
really we're now ik waiting the drawing
of a picture - yelling fire in a theatre
a picture
is hateful drawing a picture is that it
is my life how is it not hateful for
Islam to infringe on our culture there
are Christians there are Jews there are
plenty of other people from other faiths
who have done the exact same thing
they've done the exact same thing please
point me to it please show me where
Christians have tried to kill people for
drawing a picture of Jesus
please show me where people have blown
up thousands of audience members that
Jesus Christ Superstar
don't worry I'll wait we have to be very
careful here when you when you provoke
people and incite people that doesn't
make violent actions right but don't be
surprised that it happens and these
people are not only putting Americans
here at home at risk they're putting
American servicemen abroad at risk and
that's what they don't seem to
understand the same thing with the guy
down in Florida who wanted to burn a
bunch of qur'an's
you know we pay the price for this or
Americans serving in Afghanistan Iraq
and elsewhere who are targeted by
extremists and that is simply not fair
okay people always say what why do you
have to politicize everything this is
why liberalism breeds absolute pansies
because he doesn't understand here okay
those soldiers who've lost those lives
those heroes who they won't call a hero
by the way who've lost their lives did
so in protecting the freedom for someone
to be able to burn a quran guarantee if
you went to those soldiers guarantee if
you went to them before they died and
said hey hey listen you know what some
muslims are gonna be really mad cuz some
guy burnt two quran do you blame them or
is your death in their hands they
wouldn't say they wouldn't say so for a
second they'd say no I'd probably lay
the burden of my killing squarely on the
shoulders of the terrorists who are
forbidding the freedom that I'm fighting
to protect oh let me ask you about the
predictable factor maybe I shouldn't use
the word cause because but we induced
something as a predictable reaction to
it you're pretty much getting there my
question is this how often does this go
on do you know that they have these
displays of anti Mohammed artifacts and
paintings
how often do they have them without
event with that reaction oh I can answer
that question Chris apparently you don't
have enough producers to do a Google
search all the time and I know some
people are going to get upset by the
cussing here okay I'm not someone who
gets up on traditional news outlets and
always just sound
the doomsday siren America is circling
the drain right now
freedom is absolutely circling the drain
and if you don't get it clearly they
don't get it you don't deserve the
privilege you don't deserve the luxury
of freedom if you're even willing to
entertain the idea that maybe we
shouldn't draw a picture to appease a
group of people who might kill us for
doing so
you don't deserve the privilege of
freedom how is it not hateful for them
to infringe on our right to free speech
it's the code on which our country was
literally founded why do we have to be
more sensitive to their beliefs than
they do with ours how is it not more
hateful to say hey you can't draw that
picture well really why not well if you
do we just can't protect you that's not
only hateful that's evil which is worse
because hating something isn't
inherently evil you just have to hate
the right things
am i hateful sure I hate that Muhammad
called for the deaths of Christians and
Jews I hate that Muhammad married a six
year old and beat the crap out of her I
hate that Muslims like in this case feel
entitled to the moral superiority in
telling us what we can and cannot draw
those things I hate I also really hate
the self-proclaimed conservative news
outlets and media out there who are too
cowardly to run these images themselves
I hate that these conservative outlets
will plaster themselves in red white and
blue and be one of the folks and sang
some country songs but when push comes
to shove and there is a line drawn in
the sand to stand up for liberty or to
yield they cower in the face of
political correctness that I really hate
to the conservatives who won't run these
images you deserve to lose you deserve
to lose and by the way we're not just
talking about terrorism here we're not
talking about a few lone extremists the
religion of Islam an overwhelming number
of Muslims believe that drawing a
picture of Mohammed should be a
punishable sin drawing a picture should
be a punishable sin isn't
that extremists enough if you liked this
video subscribe by clicking my face and
if you hated it well join the club and
you're gonna hate this next video right
next to me but doesn't a part of you
wanna know what it is